You're listening to radiolab from New York public radio, public radio, W,
N Y,
c n n p r m Jetta boom Rod.
And I'm Robert Krulwich and this is radio lab. You ever wondered why it is, um,
that all living things die? I do wonder about that actually,
which it keeps me up at night, which always leads me to the next question.
Do we have to,
do I have to the topic of our show as a matter of fact and the natural place to
begin to look for an answer. [inaudible] is in a garage.
[inaudible] so here we are in your garage or ar in my garage.
The owner of this particular garage is one Leonard Hayflick. He is a biologist.
He takes me to the corner where he's got this about. So what,
describe what we're looking at here. Well,
what we're looking at is I barrel shaped a divides metal canister,
metal.
It side is shaped kind of like a thermos except big opening lid.
He twits off the top and that
out comes all of this smoke dry ice from Halloween is what it looks. Well,
this liquid hydrogen is used in a lot of movies.
He reaches his hand into the liquid nitrogen fog right into the bowels of this
canister and pulls out. And this is what I'd come to see.
Those are what some test tubes,
who boobs and which the samples are kept immediately there not much to look at.
If you know what's in there, it's almost holy. Each tube has millions,
a frozen human cells in there.
And these cells have completely changed how we think about mortality and
mortality. And You keep it in your garage. Yes. Why? I mean,
I think it's pretty cool, but why? Why it goes,
nobody else think of looking here. Oh, okay. Well, I want,
I certainly wouldn't divulge your address or anything, but just don't tell him.
No, of course I wouldn't, but it's in California is all I'll say. Well,
where else would you want me to put it in mind? But still, I don't know. I mean,
it's, uh, I imagined something like this.
You would find it in the middle third for Leonard Hayflick about 50 years ago.
I got the backstory, actually not in California. In Philly. Sound check.
Do you want to tell me where we are?
Where we're sitting on the 12th floor of the William Penn House in Philadelphia,
Pennsylvania,
which happens to be my mother's apartment who has just celebrated her hundredth
birthday just that day. Appropriately enough. In any case,
let's rewind to the 50s biology was facing a problem. Basic problem.
How do you study human cells? Cells are us.
It is what we are, but you can't exactly put a microscope up to your wrist.
I will. You know, I guess you could, but I wouldn't say it's impossible,
but it's certainly highly impractical what you can do instead,
and Hayflick was among the first to perfect. This is it. Well,
he explained it to me.
If I take a tiny biopsy from any part of your anatomy that you're willing to
surrender to me, like say a flick of mine, like my wrist, your wrist,
kind of anywhere you want, the tip of your nose and to be your toe.
I don't care where it is.
And then you raise a pyramid of skin by grabbing onto the tip of a hair,
pull it up, and then with the other hand, you'd take a sterile scalpel and y
the tip of that pyramid of skin off.
And I drop it into a test tube and I introduce an enzyme preparation called
trypsin. And that material dissolves
the cement that holds all the cells together.
Think of your tissue as a brick wall.
And once I dropped that brick wall into my test of I need to dissolve the
mortar,
right?
And now I have your individual cells NFI feed them and treat them nicely.
They will divide
[inaudible].
Each cell produced two cells.
Hmm.
Each cell produced two cells to sell, to sell.
Did you do the Badmouth?
You find that they'll cover the city of New York in about three weeks?
I mean, you know, that's if you had a big enough petri dish. In any case,
this process, it's called cell culturing,
is the simplest thing in the world these days.
I mean modern biologists can do it with their eyes close the back in Hayflick's
Day in the fifties it was very fuzzy because no one really understood the
mechanics of it. No one knew exactly what a cell liked or what it didn't like.
And so the people that were really good at getting the cells to divide from two
and four and eight and 16 whatever. Yes, they, it was like they had the touch.
They had what was called a green thumb.
There was a mystique about them because, you know, don't forget,
this was the early days. Biology,
biology at that time was kind of a black art.
Well,
I'm interested in the use of the term black art because that attribute was given
to the field by a single individual who dominated the field for about 20 or 30
years. His name was Alexis corral.
He believed that the contamination of tissue cultures with airborne bacteria
could be eliminated or prevented by maintaining sterile circumstances.
That in his mind included everything being painted black
[inaudible]
no, don't ask me the rationale for that because I can't explain it. So Guthrie.
I love it exactly.
All of his technicians on he himself were dressed from head to foot and black
and he had a gallery around the lab where reporters could wander to see these
mystical black figures roaming the laboratory and keep Glor doing strange things
with strange implements and ending up with cells growing.
It must've seemed like wishcraft on.
It didn't seem like they believed it was witchcraft,
especially because Alexis corral claimed to have kept a chick heart alive for 46
years at chick heart. Yes, the heart of a baby chicken.
It was a fragment of tissue from the chick heart, so for 46 years,
the cells divided and divided every couple of days. That's what was alleged.
Now, 46 years is a long time. Right?
So scientists thought that if they've gone this long,
they'll probably go forever
because of corral and a couple other scientists.
It was thought that cells are immortal under the proper conditions,
the grow indefinitely and corrals.
Little chicken heart seemed to be proof of this.
It just kept spewing new cells,
which he keep dividing into new bottles. The New York Post said, quote,
if all of the cells produced by Dr Carell from his cultured chicken heart were
kept together,
they would produce a rooster that could cross the Atlantic Ocean in a single
shoe.
Yeah.
Well they wish I'd come up with that myself. Now,
was that a quote that was made lovingly or admiringly or was that a sort of
sneers made to sell the New York Post, but two people bought it,
I guess is what I'm asking. You're darn right. They bought it until it was tour
by me. Right. Well, that's the story that I want to get to next.
It happened by accident.
He did not set out to torpedo the rooster or the whole idea of cellular
immortality. It just kind of happened. He was in the lab.
It was the 50s he was just a kid and he becomes worried.
This was an ordinary worry at the time that his little cells would become
contaminated. I knew at the time,
the cultured normal human tissue from adults,
you might grow simultaneously unwanted viruses because in adults,
the viruses would sometimes sneak into the cells and hide there.
And I didn't want, of course, my cultures to be contaminated with these viruses.
So I zeroed in on human fetal tissue,
human fetal tissue as in from abortions,
sorry to ask an ignorant question, but it w abortion at that time was,
was it anything like the crazy political thornbush that is now no farm or
rational? It was actually quite easy. He says he just picked up the phone,
called my friends at the University of Pennsylvania and said I want an fetuses
whenever they were surgically aborted and as you might expect when you put your
order in for fetal tissue, you know, not when the phone will ring.
He never knew when the shipments would arrive.
I would receive maybe one feed is one week and then two weeks later, one.
So
to keep track of things and this turns out to be key. He kept a log.
Every time he'd get a new shipment,
he would jot down the arrival day and then drop the cells into the flask,
washed in divine, do the whole deal.
And then every couple of weeks he would come and check on them.
And that's when it started.
I began to realize that some of the cultures are unhappy. They stopped dividing.
At first it was just one, one batch. What were you thinking at this point? Uh,
I didn't know what to think because it's just an observation and it was just one
batch batch a, let's call it. Yeah. All right. No biggie. I'll see how it goes.
Come back.
Okay. Uh,
and a month later I find out that not only a is still not doing its thing,
but B and c aren't either.
Now three batches of cells had gone. Caput said to myself,
well that's peculiar.
Peculiar because here he'd done the same with these cells as he done with all
the others, put them in the same glasses, same solution, same conditions,
didn't add up. Now I have to find out what the cause is.
So I'll go back and look at my records.
And that is when it smacks him in the face.
What the thing that all three batches of sales hadn't come in,
and he knew this because he'd kept the logs, is that they were the oldest,
so to speak. He'd received each batch of fetal tissue from the hospital,
received it from the hospital roughly nine months ago.
At nine months or thereabouts,
they just kinda hit a wall and they stopped divide,
but the ones received one month, two, one three, one for my apartment.
Six months ago though sales were doing just fine, perfect, beautiful,
and he kept seeing this simultaneously.
Two thoughts enter his mind thought number one, this can't be an accident.
If it was a accident, it should be random thought. Number two,
wait a second. This has to be an accident because I had been taught by expert.
Its cells are in, they will grow forever. All right,
fast forward a few months.
Those two conflicting thoughts are still fighting and out in Hayflick's mind.
Along comes the annual biology conference, your scientific meeting in the world.
That time the meeting was held in Atlantic city.
Hayflick and a few friends decided to hop in a car and crashed the meeting
because the featured speaker was a guy.
Hey flick really admired guy by the name of Ted puck
because I want to hear what he has to say and I'm gonna.
If I can get enough guts, I'm gonna be asking a question. Hmm.
I remembered this length like it was that big hole. The housing people,
I'm sure it's in saturation,
but huge or lots of people and I'm somewhere in a little listening to this talk.
You see the match previously developed single cells and at the end as is
customary ask for questions. Are there any questions?
I timidly raised my hand.
So yes. The young fellow at the center here you,
yes. And I ask him the question, Dr. Park,
have you ever found that the cells that you culture stop dividing?
Did you want to give him a kind of that Gotcha. What were you thinking? I want,
yeah,
well I was ready to publish. I wanted to know whether I'm in trouble,
whether I have an artifact on my hands that nobody has seen because I do it
right. I see. I'm still worried. Got It.
And so he says he looks at me, you know, like in the video.
Well of course the cell stopped dividing the occasion.
Of course I lose my sales occasionally,
but I simply go back to the freezer and reconstitute.
Meaning that when the cells stop dividing, which he just had been in,
they do all the time. He just said that something happened. I don't know what.
I'll just go back to the freezer and get more. Well, that's not right,
because if they stopped dividing, they might've just died.
It's not that he was cheating, it's that he thought he had screwed up. Oh,
then I know it was a Gotcha. Well, he didn't yell. Gotcha. Right at that moment,
he just sat back down.
But now he knew it was real because even the brilliant Ted puck had seen it too,
but like everyone else for the past 60 years,
he just hadn't recognized it for what it was.
I imagine in labs all over the country,
there must've been a lot of moments when cells stopped dividing and at every one
of those moments you're saying the thought that popped into the technician's
mind is I've got
absolutely.
That seems like a crazy kind of mass delusion.
It's called dog Gerry know the definition of the word dog. Yeah,
I've heard that word before. That's it.
The concept of mortality was absent from people's minds.
Well, wait, if they didn't understand the idea of mortality,
then w how did they,
the scientists explain getting older and moving towards death for pre
torpedoing.
Yeah. Radiation. What? Radiation?
Well, no, seriously.
I mean it was this idea that like stuff is happening outside the cell,
that the radiation is bombarding the cell,
like gamma rays and Alpha rays and these kinds of things,
and then that somehow ages the cell.
So the trigger is outside the being not inside this owl.
So my discovery and I pointed it out in that first paper,
was to indicate that it's in the cell, not outside the cell.
That's where the action is.
Hayflick argued that somewhere in the cell there,
there's a counter one too. There's gotta be for something.
[inaudible] cell is the keeping track eight, nine,
10 11 because after about nine months of happy dividing in a petri dish,
when the cell gets two 50 divisions, sometimes the few takes more.
If you takes less than 50 is the average.
And when it reaches 54 45 little counter inside cell eight 49 50 says,
50 is the magic number. Where did this number 50 come from?
You'll have to ask God that question
nonetheless.
Hayflick not God has his name forever attached to that number because it's
become known as the Hayflick limit.
[inaudible].
Now,
one of the interesting things Hayflick told me while we looked at a secret stash
of fetal cells in his garage is that there is a way to tinker with the cellular
counter. If you lower the temperature by say,
putting the cells in liquid nitrogen as he has the dividing one will get slower
and slower and slower.
I don't know,
until it stops at 250 degrees below zero,
the cells will not divide and they won't die.
They'll just wait for as long as you keep them frozen.
The cells I have in my freezer, I've been frozen for,
uh, 44 years, is that make them long.
These cells are the longest frozen normal human cells in the world.
The fetal cells he's talking about incidentally,
are the ones that he used to discover the Hayflick limit.
He calls it WWI 38. What do we know
about the mother of the fetus that created WUI 38 she was a Swedish woman and
she wanted an abortion because she had many children and was very poor.
Her husband was not a good father. And uh,
that's where this tissue came from. Here's the kicker.
After the Hayflick limit experiments, these cells,
this particular strain was used to incubate and produce vaccines,
all different kinds. Polio, German, measles, measles, mumps,
rabies. In anybody born in the last 50 years,
who's had any of these vaccines has had these cells in their body.
Numbers of people who have benefited from these vaccines now exceed 1 billion
people. That's billion with a B billion with a B.
One aborted child creates a fleet of cells that vaccinate a billion people.
Think about that for a second.
And is it true that, that you have a cell line from, is it your daughter? Yes.
I also have cells in there from the amnion of my daughters, Susan Hayflick.
Do you keep them for purely scientific greens or is it sort of like stamp
collecting? You have them I,
well it would be is a scientist now herself and so I'll probably give the
ampules to her so she can do with them. My true what she wishes.
But You keep them because it's your daughter mostly? Yes, mostly. Yeah, sure.
Yeah. That's really sweet. Here's the interesting thing, scientifically,
if you were to warm these cells up, give them some food.
Oh,
they start to divide again by six and not only that,
they pick up right where they left off. And even if you froze them again,
say the 1615 doubling 16 and kept them that way for a thousand million years,
wouldn't matter. Because as soon as you unfroze them off,
they'd go 1718 1920 on their way to 52 23 without missing a beat.
What does that tell you? Tells you that the cells,
remember they have a memory
somehow the cell always remembers where it is in the count to 50 oh self-care
count. How do they do that? Oh, that's, and that was the next big question.
So we set about to do a number of experiments. However,
the next big breakthrough came in 1971 and not by Hayflick while he was doing
his experiments in Philly, halfway across the world, the very same moment,
a Russian named Alexia love knockoff was attending a lecture to lecture in the
house. Hey, flux research,
and he left that lecture puzzled by this question that you asked.
How do the cells remember [inaudible]?
Have you ever been in Moscow? Well anyhow,
so he ended the Moscow subway station,
went down to [inaudible] platform and suddenly he had an insight.
He had a brilliant insight. When you looked at the railroad track,
the first thing you thought was those tracks look a lot like DNA.
If you take real attraction, you twist it. Yeah, you got DNA. Okay,
say it some DNA and that DNA, his job is to count to 50 and then yell, ah,
well we know part of the DNA has the job of yelling, but the other stuff,
the rest of it, what if it's just a long sequence of nonsense?
Nonsense. What if every time that cellular copier comes along to copy the cell,
you lose one little piece of it. The nonsense. Well,
if you had say 50 pieces of nonsense as a buffer around the sense part,
the switch,
well then it would take 50 copies to snowy all the nonsense until you left with
the switch, which would turn on and tell the Senate to stop
fine.
Back in Philadelphia. As we were wrapping up that first interview,
a question occurred to me, if we kind of understand how that off switch works,
shouldn't we theoretically be able to take her out,
had a tinker with when the switch gets switched?
In theory, I suppose you could. Yeah, sure.
And within that allow us to have a longer amount of cell divisions.
Well, that's certainly,
it doesn't violate any knowledge about the system of course.
And wouldn't that theoretically give us something,
whether it be extended life or something?
Yes, certainly.
Hey, flicker clearly been asked this question a million times and he patiently
explained to me that there is a way right now that we can tinker with the timing
of the switch. You take an enzyme called telomerase. Telomerase,
throw it into the mix and every time that cell gets copied and loses pieces of
track, the telomerase enzyme comes along and adds in back on. Mm.
And maintains the length constant. That way the track is always long.
The stop switch never gets switched and the cell keep going
and going and going. That's how they become mortal.
So you're not going to tell me, well that's an articulate.
Everybody would Tom rice. Yeah. And well if you volunteer,
we'll have a shot at it. Are you ready there? There must be.
If I were to go out and shout from your balcony right here,
I'm sure I get a hundred people who'd want to try.
Really not after I tell you what, you still don't know. What's that?
95% of all tumors contain telomerase,
which normal cells do not contain.
The single most distinguishing criteria between normal and cancer cells known
today is that fact.
So the tradeoff for cellular immortality, at least in this case, is cancer.
But here's the weird thing. If you look around,
you will see that our Hayflick limit of 50 is not the only one.
We do know that if you look at the normal cells of a Galapagos tortoise,
which has been reported in the literature, uh,
they undergo about 125 doublings, if I remember correctly.
So their Hayflick number is one 25 and ours is 50 apparently. Yes.
Does that correlate to the Galapagos turtle living twice as long? Well, it seem,
it seems to, but that comparison may be anecdotal. I'm not universal.
That's what Hayflick is up to these days.
He's become fascinated by animals who age differently than us,
who might have a doubling limit of, you know,
200 500 or no limit at all are the whole class of animals that don't age will
get like what the American lobster lobster doesn't age.
It either does not age or the rate is so slow.
We can't measure it. I don't even know how to imagine that. What does that mean?
That it does, what it means is that the animal gets bigger and bigger.
She's growth. Yes, there are lobsters that have been found. I are recently,
I read about one of those over 50 pounds.
Okay.
I looked it up. The largest lobster ever reported was close to yes.
50 pounds found in the 1950s just off the coast of New Jersey.
Hey, New Jersey. Yep. How old? How old is a 50 pound lobster? Who knows?
Occasion was wearing a Grover Cleveland for president button.
So I'm Jad Abumrad Robert Krulwich Radiolab. We'll be right back.
My name is AUC Srivastava and I'm calling from the University of Chicago.
Radiolab is supported in part by the National Science Foundation and by the
Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
ready? But what am I supposed to do? I don't have to do anything. Right.
This is Radiolab. I'm Jad up.
I'm Rod and I'm Robert Krulwich and today we're talking about aging.
Yep. Thank you. I wonder why it is that that human beings live. Um,
like what, how long do we live? About 70 years roughly. Something like that.
Yeah.
So why 70 as opposed to seven or like 700 why that number?
Well, that's know. That's a good question because every,
apparently every creature has for some reason a sort of natural range.
So do you want to hear? Very cool one. Um,
how about a rat got a rat in your head? Yeah.
And a squirrel. The rat and the squirrel here you have two animals people call.
Oh, I have friends who call squirrels tree rats that Cynthia Kenyon from the
University of California, San Francisco. I recently paid her a visit.
They're very similar to each other. They're rodents,
but Arat has a three year lifespan,
whereas a squirrel has a 25 year lifespan
and no one knows why. Really? There are theories, but no one really knows why.
I got the idea that maybe somehow lifespan was evolvable in the sense that there
might be genes in the animal,
which when change allow big leaps in lifespan to take place.
So you figured that you could just hunt the jeans down. Exactly.
And this is exactly what she seems to have done,
but not with rats and squirrels. With what? What did I show you?
The incubator where we keep all the ones with worms,
little roundworms yet called the sea elegance. Actually,
you can't see them with a naked eye. They're just a little speck.
But when you put them under a microscope, you see how beautiful they are.
So first I'm showing you here the normal warm when it's a young adult.
And what you can see is it's very active and it's healthy looking.
So we're looking at this in the dishes looking great, moving from,
it's a wiggle. It moves really nicely. Okay,
now let's fast forward two weeks.
Then she showed us a different set of words in a different dish.
These worms were 13 days, day 13 of adulthood.
They only lived to 14 just live two weeks here at the very,
very end of their lives. And what we see here as a dead one.
So one has already died and another one that's clearly in the nursing home,
just lying, still not moving at all. And you can tell immediately that it's old.
It looks kind of wrinkled and lethargic.
And even if you've never seen a worm ever, you can tell that one is old,
so there you got it. You got a young worm, you have an old woman.
Essentially what Cynthia Kenyon is trying to do is she's trying to hunt down the
gene that could turn that old worm backwards in time and make it look like a
young word. The worms have about 20,000 genes, so the idea is really simple.
You just go and change genes at random one by one,
one at a time and see whether any of these gene changes can extend life span.
How long did it take you to bump into a good one? Well, we, we actually,
we're really lucky to find a gene pretty quickly and we found that if we change
this one gene called Daf too, if we change this one gene called Daf too,
then the worms live twice as long as as they normally do.
Just like that, pretty much really sheer luck.
She taken this worm and stretched its lifespan for 14 days all the way out to
about 28 days. Just 28 yeah. It doesn't sound like a lot to you,
but to where I'm next.
Wait, can you tell me like w w when you ran into it,
did you do a like a little war dance around the laboratory where you now?
That was amazing. I mean it was incredible. I had a,
a person in my lab who said Daft to his magic and she's right. Okay.
I'm going to show you these magic worms,
which are exactly the same as the normal worms,
except that we've changed one gene, the def two gene.
You remember that old wrinkly worm that we saw before?
The whim she's about to show me is the same age as a 13 day old.
Were you the old way? Okay. And it's bolting out of,
it's bolting into the picture here. It looks young. It's moving.
It's very healthy. It's active. And actually if you take a microscope,
then you look at the tissues.
What you see is the tissues of the warm look young.
If you just look at that,
you just sit there and you just look at it and look at it and look at it and
just let it sink in what it means. It's really amazing.
It's really a very deep and fundamental.
You're looking at something that I guess wasn't supposed to happen in some funny
way. There was supposed to die.
Sure. What exactly is this gene doing to make them live longer? Well,
maybe I should, we should ask,
ask the question a different way because the worms that lived longer,
they didn't actually have this working gene, right?
When we make a mutation in the Daf two gene,
we damage it and that actually causes it not to work as well.
So that actually is kind of profound.
That tells you right away that the worm has a gene in it that shortening the
worms lifespan, which is why she calls it the Green Murray Burgy,
the grim reaper gene. It's the gene that makes you,
if you're aware, right. So by damaging this gene,
Cynthia and her team essentially are taking the grim reaper
and knocking it out and stop that. Okay. So the question is,
what exactly is the def to doing to make the cell age more quickly?
Here's where the story gets a little weird.
Well, we found another gene whose name is also daft, but it's a different app.
It's called deaf 16 and this is a gene whose normal function is to keep you
young.
It's like a fountain of youth change to we there.
There was a grim he virgin before, right?
And now there's a fountain of youth genes. That's what she discovered.
And inside the worms, these jeans are struggling with each other.
Here's how it works. When it, when a worm ages,
normally the Daf two receptor to kind of squash this,
the activity of Daf 16 it turns it
silence.
And so the worm ages, okay,
so when you come along and you inhibit the activity of the deaf too,
or separate, oh, now you liberate Dev 16 right? It's free.
It springs into action and it activates about a hundred genes
in the DNA.
These hundred genes each to a little tiny good thing for the cell.
And altogether it makes the cell live twice as long.
[inaudible]. So let me just back up your show. There's the bay, there's the,
there's the, there's the bad gene, the gene that says, all right,
everybody died. But the way that it tells everybody dies,
it goes to particularly over to this little guy over in the corner,
who's the good guy who's repairing and protecting and fighting disease.
And it says the conquered on the head,
like some kind of three stooges things is you shut up. Exactly.
So if that good guy can stay vibrant,
then we are in the bowling game for a little while longer. Exactly. Very good.
And you can get a lifespan that may increase,
say 100% like the one I mentioned even longer, even threefold. Three fold.
How would you do that? Well,
we found that the signals from the reproductive system affect aging.
It turns out Kenyon and her team found that if you steal away some of the worms,
baby making powers, that alone makes them live longer if you do that.
So what we did,
and if you crippled the grim reaper genes and if you strengthen the fountain of
Youth Gene, the best possible change, we knew how to make,
well now we're talking,
we get incredibly healthy animals that are live to be
six times
[inaudible]
on average, which would be like 500 years for a human and they're so healthy.
It's incredible. Okay,
so that would be like Ben Franklin still being around playing golf. It's, yeah,
it would be, it's just blows your mind to think about it, which by the way,
that doesn't mean that it will ever be possible in humans.
And why do we turn there by the way, listening to this program. No,
she kind of has to say that because she's a scientist.
She doesn't know yet whether it affects us. Um, on the other hand,
she has started a company, yes, Elixir.
And the company is making a pill and it's a pill for people. Interestingly,
have you any notion of, of how much you could slow down the process though?
We don't know. You know, we're just hoping that we can slow it down at all.
But just imagine used to be people would talk about that,
but as the world of fairytales and fantasy and now it sort of reopens the quest
for the found of youth in a new molecular way.
[inaudible]
how did the, wait a second though. What happens if she,
dare I say it succeeds with this little pill of hers.
Do we necessarily want a lot of 500 year old golfers hanging around?
Didn't the ones that not not getting out of the way. Oh, we're already,
they're gonna. In some places in the world, in Germany and in Japan,
the population of older people has grown to the point where you,
if you're a middle aged or younger, you feel the oppression
of having so many people to support [inaudible] for a second.
Japan might be a canary in the coal mine as it were.
Sort of a glimpse of where we're all headed. Jocelyn Ford,
a reporter has been looking at aging societies in Asia and recently took a trip
back to Japan where she used to live to see how they're dealing with things and
I arrived in Japan.
It was immediately obvious that that there was something different here.
I went into the closest little town to the airport and uh,
there was a festival street festival going on. I
went down the street and what really surprised me is I think it's treat families
and kids playing and you know, let's go out with a family.
But everyone was sitting around listening to the music was, um,
there were a lot of gray heads.
I met a guy who was like 90 years old and he was on a bicycle
and he cycled off. I felt it's a different society.
Bottom line is this job in Japan easing is very fast.
The fastest ever in the entire world. This guy banging the chalkboard,
that's Hubo gala hero gala.
I'm a demographer at the neon university population research institute.
Where is that by the way? Is it in Tokyo, Tokyo?
And he said that the reason that Japan looks so old all of a sudden it's because
in part people are living longer. But that's not the big reason.
The big reason is that the birth rate is falling and Japanese population is
shrinking. They're not having as many kids already. That's exactly it. I mean,
and this is something that's happening all over the developer world.
People are having smaller families and as a result,
there are fewer young people or older people right now. And in fact,
the proportion of the elderly 65 and over is a more than 21% which are the
highest anti world. 21% elderly. Can you imagine what that looks like? No,
just thank me. Thank Florida.
What do you think of when you think of Florida? Florida?
I think of beaches and I do. Well,
that's where a lot of old folks go to retire. So I think it's of a lot of,
you know, 70 and 80 year olds. Florida is the oldest state in the United States,
but compared to Japan, it's young.
It's only 17% over 65 and Japan is 21% whoa.
So imagine that all of Japan looks like Florida,
just older and OCO expects that percentage to double in 40 years. Oh,
right now, I mean, can I read a picture, the future scenario,
but it's going to change.
I got some insight into that change back at the street fair.
I went to get some tea and rice crackers. I in that shot,
it was a 103 year old.
Granted I tried to talk to her but she couldn't really communicate,
but she didn't, I don't
really know what was going on. Um, her daughter was in her sixties.
His is the main caretaker under 16 in her sixties and she has to,
the granny can no longer get out of her wheelchair by herself.
She can't take a bath. She's completely dependent on her daughter like a baby.
But she's a lot heavier than a baby. And her,
her daughter had really strained her back and hurt herself.
I mean the elder looking after the agent basically.
And that's probably the biggest, the biggest problem.
The problem is that the caregivers, uh,
primary of the caregivers is about a forties and 50s.
So we are sort of short on caregiver.
That never occurred to me that from society's perspective, the reason kids are,
are good or useful is so that they take care of the old people. Yeah.
Like government spokesman I, I spoke with you,
thank you so much for making this tiny Gucci. He,
he was quite concerned about about that there was going to be a shortage of
labor as society ages and someone has got to fill the void in countries like the
United States. We might import foreign labor. Sure.
Bringing immigrants care for the elderly, you know,
but in Japan it will happen only reluctantly.
It's not so simple because this society is still debating whether it's going to
be a good thing or not to increase numbering immigrants.
We have decided to open our a, our labor market to some extent.
[inaudible] and other government spokesman first we'll start said the government
has decided they can allow more than 100 a hundred Filipino caregivers to come
into the country. Just a a hundred. Just A, a hundred. Huh?
I know what you're thinking. Is it basically, is it basically because Japan is,
you know, phobic,
well, um, let's put it this way.
Japanese people tend to
have this island concept.
Having more international workers in our neighborhood.
Might I do that kind of tradition?
I think that's what the Japanese people might be worried about.
What's wrong with that? Things change. I think basically the communication,
particularly when he's sick, I mean when you're bedridden,
if the nurses are foreign foreigners you have to communicate and it's very
difficult.
You know, some people might think that's xenophobic phobic, that people don't,
don't want to deal with foreigners. But that's not really what it's about. Um,
people don't want to be a burden to anybody.
They don't want to depend on anybody. I don't want to
hop same button. If you say this is Mr Suga, he's a demographic researcher.
You just don't want to be a burden. No.
This feeling that you shouldn't be a burden. It runs very deep physically,
psychologically a ball swapped him.
I just prefer I will be helped not by any other people.
Why is that? Just a feeling?
It might cause problems with them, with other people.
So you'd be more comfortable knowing that you're not putting anyone else causing
them trouble. Yep. Yep. Yep.
So if I will need some help from other people,
I might want to kill myself. That's how extreme it gets.
This is a young man who's 30, he said,
I would rather commit suicide than be taken care of by somebody who doesn't want
to take care of me. Who, who I'd be a burden on. You know, uh,
there is a culture like two, 300 years ago in Japan,
if all two hormones a life until like 60,
70 years old. Then family, take this,
this old mothers to a mountain and stay there.
Make the modern state here it is a very long tradition in Japan of they call it,
uh,
or bass or busty Obamian is it grandma and stamens too.
To throw up, throw away your serious, have, have whole movies about this.
In Japan,
there's one called [inaudible], the ballot of not Yammer.
It's set in a very poor rural village about a hundred years ago.
It tells the story of a son in his old mother up the mountain
on the way up. They pass by another son,
literally filling his father off of a cliff.
[inaudible]
it makes a family happier.
So grandma stays in the mountain and starts. Yep. Yep.
Any family is happier because there's less of a burden, right?
It was understood among all the generations.
This was the way the problem was solved.
Not Anymore, obviously. Right? Right.
Japan is really quite socialist these days. They look after everyone in society,
but that idea is still out there. So what do you do today?
You don't want your kids to take care of you.
You don't want foreigners to take care of you. Who's left? Well,
one solution is instead of having people do these jobs have machines,
machines, robots, robots,
you joking. It's not actually a joke. Um,
Panasonic and others are manufacturing robots as caregivers.
When you think about it, sort of make sense.
Why don't we automate the heavy duty [inaudible] welcome to meet all.
If it did a bunch of labs and met with some scientists.
This Robert is connected to here. They've got robots that will,
it looks like a dentist chair or your wheelchair,
where to go and how fast this is going.
There's a special pair of trousers that you can put on and if your legs are weak
and you can't walk, it will help you walk. There's a washing machine robot.
It looks like it's got a fancy handle.
It's actually for washing people or any of these natural use. Yes they are.
Will do not want to have to ask somebody to clean their diapers to wash their
bum. Right. I think for anybody in any society,
that is a difficult thing to have to ask somebody more. I mean don't,
you don't have to talk. You just press a button.
Now this is where I start to get weirded out.
I went to a nursing home about an hour and a half outside of Tokyo,
some to lots of people and must be sitting around.
There's a television about three people are watching the TV ones looking out the
window.
I walked in and there were a lot of old people just sitting around each keeping
mostly to themselves, sitting very quietly.
Oh talking. It was sort of sad in steps.
Pero the seal
pro is one of the world's first therapy robots get it? No.
What does that mean?
What they've done is they've made this are like a large stuffed animal,
white for really long eyelashes and flutters them at you and it squeals.
When Pearl came out, one of the grantees just lit up,
got so excited.
She peered into the seals eyes and she tried to talk to it
to come to puddle it. Same feeling, feeding her family,
come here. I was taken back.
I mean it's not much more than a moving stuffed animal.
And how could you look at it and see companies see something alive.
See something comforting, feeling a little bit warm. Is Pero warm? Yes.
I spoke to the developer, Mr she bought it for your warm blooded, Huh?
He said yeah,
they wanted a creature that would give them positive feedback but also sort of
made them being stroked is good for puddle.
So part tried to be stroked by the owner like you're doing right now.
Did you program to want to be whole.
He also programmed them to respond to different names by call him as puddle.
If you give a new name like John or something or like Choco Chan and call it the
new name again, again
the new name and start the response
so it's learning you down carefully because we don't want to hurt you. Oh,
you want to be held again. They learn from their environment.
Now these are really rudimentary, you know, beginning baby robots,
but it worked, Jed, it worked.
They adored it. They were loving it and it was loving them in their minds.
I started to think maybe this is a solution.
People might actually be able to engineer compassion, engineer, companionship.
But then I started asking a lot of people around me,
it took an informal Straw poll.
Would you feel comfortable with a robot taking care of you?
And most people said, no,
not really doing a lot [inaudible] like this woman [inaudible] she actually came
up with a brilliant idea, which seems like a no brainer.
She has a nursing home which is together with a preschool.
Yes. That actually you to take a tour
[inaudible]
you walk into the room and you are bombarded by these little parties and the
flying around is just over the top.
Well
and it's a toxic in a few an old person in that environment,
you have no time whatsoever to dwell on the idea that you dying.
Yeah,
the kids are, they demand your attention but you need, you
need it again. But the first thing that you told us,
the very beginning is that there are more old folks, the less kids. Well,
what happens when these kids were listening to right now when they
[inaudible] there's just a bunch of old people around and there's going to be
one kid left and they all go to visit that one kid. I mean that, that,
that can't work. You expect me to have an answer? We'll be,
we should import kids. I don't know. No, I mean you're joking obviously,
but when I guess what I'm asking is like w are we left at the end to to think
that the society cannot support all of its members getting old.
That somehow the old half to step out of the way that I think your thinking is
basically old fashioned. They will be more old people in fewer young people.
That's a fact. You're not going to turn the clock back on this.
Societies do change. People do come up with new ideas and right now,
hey they're stabbing the dark after them,
but one day they'll come up with a solution. So learn to deal with it.
Tammy, you just bitch slap me.
What do you call it? Me. All the way across the Pacific Ocean.
Across the whole continent. Darn it.
We got a break now cause they got to sort of pick up my ego here.
Radio lamp will continue in a moment.
This is Casey calling from Fort Myers Beach, Florida.
Radiolab is supported in part by the National Science Foundation and by the
Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
this is Radiolab. I'm Jad, I'm rod and I'm Robert Krulwich.
And in this hour we've been talking about aging mostly,
but now we're going to turn our attention to the end of that aging process while
you're talking about dying. Yes.
Maybe we've avoided that topic because that's generally
how people deal with death, which is to avoid it. To deny it. Yeah.
So this next piece is about actually a different way of dealing with death,
I should say, before we begin it,
that it does contain some graphic descriptions of the normal bodily process of
aging.
But if you have someone in the room who is squeamish or you don't think should
hear these things and it's nothing, you know, terrible. It's just,
it's actually quite nasty. Yes. Nasty, nasty. Uh,
then maybe this is the time to shoot them out of the room.
This piece was produced by Lou old Koski. It's about one family,
three generations in introduce myself. This is Jeremiah the youngest. Um,
Jeremiah is Hagar. He's a filmmaker. So I don't know if Isaiah Zig are his dad.
Isaiah is a muralist, his grandfather, I'm the grandson of Asher's.
They go, [inaudible] art is a health nut.
[inaudible] they flow all my shit.
This is a video of him that Jeremiah's shot of aster doing his daily exercise
routine.
He's in his nineties he's jumping on a trampoline and counting each chunk.
How old are you now?
I'm 90 90 you're in healthy man for 90 yeah.
No healthy. When I'm 91 92 the great,
great grandfather that I named lived to 100
so you're going to live to 102 I don't know, but maybe
at the age of 93 Asher began to decline
quickly. How did you deal with a man dying in your house?
How do you deal with that?
Well,
you know my father and starts taking photos of him.
One of my modes of understanding was either drawing or photographing.
He was always taking pictures of my grandfather. Just see housings of slides.
Thousands.
Ah,
that's how it went for awhile. Isaiah,
the dad would take care of his dad and take some photos. Wow.
Grandson Jeremiah basically looked the other way.
Well, I never really knew my grandfather,
but then Isaiah got an idea. I thought to myself, challenged
this young boy to this duel who can take the most objective photographs of a
dying man.
It wasn't like we threw down and like I pulled my camera out of my holster and
he pulled his camera out of his holster. You know, it wasn't like that.
He was involved in my grandfather's death and I wasn't. And so he said,
this is how I get involved.
[inaudible]
it's my senior year in high school. Um,
and I was a bus boy in this restaurant down the street and I loved it.
And I would bust tables til two or three in the morning and then I would get
drunk with people after work and then I would come back and I would take care of
my grandpa.
So I would lift them up and change the sheets because otherwise his bedsore
would burn more when he had this horrible bedsore you can see it in the
photographs and he would hit me while I lifted him up and then I would
photograph him cause I would want to sit with him.
Cause when you're wanting calm him down and the way you sit with him,
I mean my father was right, you have a camera. I mean that's how you cope.
Otherwise you're sitting with him and he's just looking at you during the
contest.
Dad and son shared duties of taking care of Grandpa and at night they'd sit at
the kitchen table and compare photos. As soon as I took the first pictures,
you knew mine were better than my father is because my father is or from far
away. And there were snapshots and mine were like specific.
Like I was fascinated with him dying. I wanted to know what it looked like.
And this went on for about a month. One that during which time,
even Jeremiah's friends, all of his friends got involved. I,
the wee hours of the night I would wake up and I would see that they're
surrounding my father or four or five young people.
Sure they were drinking beer and they were joking around, but they were there.
They were there while he was there. What I remember most was, uh,
you and your friends changing his sheets and, uh,
lifting them and moving them around. [inaudible] who else did it with you?
John Lincoln. Hey,
all became initiated into the most problematic event in our lives.
It was an amazingly rare scene to see these teenagers attending to death.
Well, this is a book of photographs of a, my father,
your grandfather's last week of life in this very room.
So the contest was a month long. Smart Guy. I am. Huh?
You're good. You know how to make the contest. I kept it gone for one month.
Gotcha. Huh? Is that,
can you describe this one pretty well? The feet look like they're,
um,
they were out in the desert that they'd been baked and cracked and dry,
dry, dried out. I mean, look at them. They look like, I mean,
look at the nail in the hell. It's wild. But I mean everything. It's like what?
I have these same legs. You stop touching photos.
Well, I can almost feel him like feeling them. I feel you instead there,
that's the bed. Bedsore that's what happens.
Sure. Oh, it's awful. Awful, awful,
awful, awful, awful man who prided himself on his health. Look what happened.
How does one describe that? It looks like riding me.
I mean they just opened wounds and you're moving them around, moving around,
but still it was impossible.
It's crazy to look at the too pink and then white,
green and then ground where it's rather white is the muscle isn't.
I took these photos in color because I'm black and white. You'd never get it.
You know, you'd never get how painful this must've been.
His anus is all red.
I mean like really red and you can see the parts of it have broken and there's
just blood gushing it and it's dried. I mean the blood is dried. Thank.
This is the last photo. This one
you can see like the cognition just go on the mouth is a cake.
He's buried in his pillow. He knew it was over. It was just a matter of time.
Now that's it. That's the closest I got him dying.
He wanted to live forever.
[inaudible]
the fix was in from the beginning.
The fix is that I was supposed to add. Sure, sure.
How could it be any other way? I don't know. I could have taken that.
I could give it up. And you wanted me to,
when it was a subterfuge to get you to be with your grandfather as much as
possible. I thought it was a Fairfax. It wasn't, ah, can,
can there ever, you all already couldn't take a good picture.
When a person is dying, it's very important that they're surrounded.
[inaudible]
they're surrounded by the light of life and you don't go in to the place of
oblivion
alone. Do you want me to be there?
I don't know at this point. I don't know. I'm not, I'm not at that place yet.
Well what does that mean with the camera? I mean, just be with me. Yeah.
Be with me. Be close to me. Be Soft with me. Yeah,
I guess that's what it's about really. [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
thanks to Lou l Koski for that story and to Isaiah and Jeremiah are,
well, we've come to the end of our hour. I guess we should wrap, um,
we should mention the website. Yes. radiolab.org is the address.
And also if you want to sign up for our podcast, how do you do that? Well,
you go to radiolab.org or to iTunes directly,
and if you want to send us an email, Robert, if you want to send us an email,
you should really write us to our email address, which you can never remember.
Radio lab at W N Y C dot. Org is our email address.
I'm Jad Abumrad and I'm Robert Krulwich. We'll see you later.